[Music]
hi everyone thank you very much for
coming I know we still have a bunch of
people coming in we've got so much
material to cover I really want to make
sure we get started on time thanks also
to everyone joining on the livestream
we're going to talk about canary
deployments using sto and kubernetes
with spinnaker or other tools my name is
Andrew Phillips I'm a product manager
and GCP working on continuous delivery
and I'm Nora Lutz site reliability
engineer at Descartes labs but I like to
say that I'm a recovering systems admin
I've been in the sim Street for just
under ten years got my start in
high-performance computing and research
at Old Dominion University around three
years ago I moved into geospatial and
Earth Observation at NASA and it was
around that same time I started working
within the kubernetes ecosystem so now
I'm at Descartes labs and I'm really
excited to share some of the stuff we'll
be working on thanks Dora so let me
briefly give a quick overview of what
we're going to try and cover today I'm
gonna start with a quick introduction to
what's the actual challenge what's the
problem we want to address I'm going to
do a very quick recap of what kubernetes
also offers out of the box for
application rollouts we're going to use
some of those options to talk about the
pattern that you can use to implement
canary analysis we're gonna talk about
what you get if you add sto into the mix
some additional options and then we're
gonna stop with a theory in my slides
and Noor is going to talk about what
this actually looks like in practice at
Descartes Labs just a quick reminder if
you have questions you can post them in
the dory there's a link in your app that
you click and feel free to post them
there at any time during the session
we've got a lot of material I hope we'll
have time to answer the questions you
can also ask questions live I think
there's a couple of mics around we'll
try and alternate I will try and get to
as many of those as we can so let's
start by briefly talking about what the
actual challenges that we want to solve
here I think we kind of all roughly know
deployment is all about moving fast
without breaking too many things
so we want to roll out new versions and
applications we want to do that safely
it should be easy we don't want people
to have to follow a 12-step cube CTL
guide or whatever it should be reliable
ideally it works well when you do it but
also if something doesn't quite work as
expected you should have good fallback
options and then of course in an ideal
world we want it to be aligned with
whatever is considered best practice and
if we're talking a kubernetes
environment a lot of that revolves
around how can we do this in a
declarative way where we focus on our
intent rather than exactly the details
of how we're trying to roll that out
so just high-level what's the scenario
that we're talking about here nothing
particularly fancy and in general I
should say the main aim from my
perspective we're not going to talk
about magic here most of you may know
all the things that we're talking about
here it's more about representing a
pattern so that you can take away with
some guidance and some confidence but
the overall scenario is they're got
version X of my application it's running
somewhere we'll assume it's serving web
traffic most of what we're going to talk
about applies equally well to
applications that do things like
processing messages of a queue but for
the purpose of the diagrams and so on
we'll assume that there's a web serving
application and then you've got a new
version Y coming out of your build
process or your CI process and you want
to switch through users over to that
application so at a high level this with
a simple diagram is you've got a load
balancer of some sort you've got a
running version of your application be
one in this case magic happens
everything is safe and reliable and
wonderful data we finish with version
two of my application running that's
really in a nutshell all that we're
going to talk about how to try to make
this work really well so a quick recap
what does kubernetes already give you
out-of-the-box most of you are probably
familiar with the deployment object
specifically if you look at the rolling
update strategy of the deployment object
there's already a pretty good option for
out-of-the-box magic if you like as we
just saw in that slide and what you get
with a deployment object is what we
might call a rolling blue-green cut over
talk about that a little bit in
second and there are also some useful
controls that you have to handle how
much over-provisioning of new resources
you want and how quickly you want the
old resources to die away specifically
there's two parameters max Serge and max
unavailable that you can use to tune
this so there's already some pretty nice
options what you get is a picture that
looks a bit like this we've got a
service you've got your deployment
object which is managing a replica set
starts out here you decide to switch to
v2 spins up on your replica set adds new
pods more another one dot dot dot
finished great so that's what you can do
out of the box and the parameters
control how many new ones you spin up
how quickly the old ones go away so
what's good about this well I guess the
best thing it works out of the box you
can pretty much do this without any real
effort you have stable naming which is
nice it means that you know the resource
name if you like that your application
workload refers to is the same like even
v1 v2 that's not part of the name you
can just pull in your workload and you
don't need to do anything low-level like
managing labels it just works
but there's also some limitations that
come with this and and when I say
limitations I should be I should be
clear this can be perfectly fine for 80
90 maybe a hundred percent of your use
cases so just because there are some
things you can't do with the deployment
object absolutely doesn't mean that it
might not be good enough for everything
that you need but for example one thing
that is not that easy to do is when a
new one of your new versions comes up
you can't really get in there and
manipulate it very well before it
actually gets traffic you can play a bit
with a health check but it's not that
easy to control that you know in a
fine-grained way the traffic cut over
process it's kind of baked into what the
deployment object does as the new pods
become healthy they get traffic you
don't have a lot of fine grained control
about that and also in terms of fallback
options like once the deployment has
happened and if you don't like the way
v2 is behaving you kind of gotta do the
process in Reverse to go back to b1 you
can get the old revision but for example
you don't have a running instance that
you can quickly switch traffic back to
so if we need some more flexibility here
we can do some things that are a little
bit more fine-grained than what the
deployment object provides and so we're
trading a little bit more effort on our
part to actually make this work with
more flexibility and more options that
we have so as an example we can do a
full Bluegreen deployments I'll show a
diagram in a second which is not a
rolling blue-green where we get the
whole new application running and then
we can do things with that and then we
can switch traffic over for example we
can use that as a pattern to carry out
more extensive validation of the new
workload before we decide to expose our
users to it so the high-level might look
something like this right so you've got
a load balancer you got your current
version of your application running you
spin up the new version so now you've
got this thing sitting there in a sort
of dark launch pattern where it's not
getting any traffic yet but the app is
running it's warmed up you can run
things against it you decide it's good
to switch your traffic over now your
users are using the new version but you
still have the old version around which
is useful you know imagine your apps
take a while to boot up if there's a
problem now you can easily switch
traffic back to the old version and
those apps will serve traffic straight
away there's no you wait and then you
you know you can have this standing
around for a while and eventually when
you're confident that the new version
really is good then of course you
probably want to get rid of the old
resources so that you don't have them
standing around forever
I actually have some wonderful slides
well I think wonderful the talk about
how to do this in detail with kubernetes
we don't have I think enough time to
cover them today if you're interested
please come up and see me afterwards so
that gives us one pattern but if we need
even more safety than this so there's a
few things that can go wrong with this
pattern no we can use that blue green
pattern that we talked about and instead
of just switching traffic over when the
new app is running we can decide to
perform some more tests we can run a
suite of integration or performance
tests or even allow a set of limited
users our internal friends or maybe a
set of EAP customers to hit the new
version of the app
we can do a sort of manual very or a
very slow rolling update if you like so
if you go back to the picture rather
than bringing up all the new instances
we can bring up a few and then we can
switch traffic over and we can slowly
slowly increase the amount of instances
that serve traffic and slowly slowly
decrease the old version and that's a
sort of it's basically what the
deployment object does but we can
control the stages in which that happens
or we can do a canary rollout which is a
another pattern that allows us to inject
some more safety into this process so I
think most of you will have heard of
this term before I'll define it for the
purposes of this discussion what is a
canary rollout well it's a way of
evaluating a candidate version which is
the new version we want to deploy
against a baseline which is related to
the currently running version most of
the time to check for unexpected
deviations of behavior so this is not
about functional testing or something
like that this is not about checking
whether the new version does what you
want it to do you know you have a new
feature you want to make sure the
feature works
no it's about verifying that the new
version behaves except ibly whatever
that means with respect to the existing
version so for example the CPU
utilization doesn't go through the roof
or something like that
and this is useful if the applications
behavior across the metrics that you're
measuring is not expected to change a
lot of course there are types of changes
imagine you've added a CPU fix where
you're expecting the applications
performance to behave quite differently
and so as part of your analysis of the
your canary to figure out whether you
should go ahead or not you need to be
able to take these kinds of expected
deviations into account as well and nor
is going to talk a little bit about some
of the ways in which canary some of the
things that you can do in your canary
analysis to make this work so what's the
schematic for a canary rollout well you
start with a load balancer you've got
your current app running and then you
move to this intermediate state in which
you have your current running app and
you have a baseline
and you have a candidate why the
baseline it's very common to see what I
might call simple canary approaches
where you just compare the candidate
with the existing version that's okay
but it's really not an apples to apples
comparison to take a simple example the
baseline or the the original version is
serving much more traffic than the
candidate so it might behave differently
just because of that it's also been
running for however long it's been
running whereas the candidate has just
booted up and so to have if you want a
proper side by side evaluation you
should have a baseline that matches the
candidate as closely as possible and
that means it should serve the same
percentage of traffic and it should have
been spun up and configured in roughly
the same way as the candidate so you run
this for a while you decide if you want
to go ahead great you can get rid of the
the baseline and the old version and
just switch all the traffic to your new
version and I'm glossing over how that
evaluation process happens nor is going
to talk a lot more about some tips and
tricks about how to get that right or if
it doesn't work out you decide okay that
wasn't a good idea
goodbye baseline goodbye candidate and
then we're back to serving traffic with
the old version and we try again so how
do we do this with kubernetes vanilla we
can use label selectors on the service
and we can use appropriate sizing of our
baseline in our candidate to approximate
the traffic distribution that we want we
could use all kinds of we could use
replica sets for instance but we would
recommend using a deployment object for
the workload just because that's the
thing kubernetes uses for these kind of
workloads and for consistency with the
way the common deployment object works
we recommend that if you do decide to go
ahead I'm instead of switching traffic
over to your candidate you actually just
update the existing deployment object in
place so that way it looks just like a
regular update if you weren't using
canary analysis so what's the schematic
if we're doing this with kubernetes
service we have a deployment we have
some label selectors that are pointing
at the current workload I'm using their
conventional ones they're useful you
might want to use your own that's not a
hard and fast
recommendation notice that the label
selector here is quite specific you'll
see why in a second why it has this
component equals server additional
selector because as we move into the
intermediate stage where we have three
deployments all of a sudden we obviously
have to loosen the label selector so
that it hits all three label selectors
on services don't support the set based
selector so that's how we're going to do
this and now we have traffic roughly
distributed across the three different
deployments and so that's where the
sizing comes in you know we have 6 + 1 +
1 and that gives us roughly this
distribution I say roughly because
that's really heavily dependent on the
characteristics of your load balancer of
your service so don't assume just
because the sizing the math of the
sizing works out like this but that's
what you're going to get if you want to
do vanilla canary with kubernetes we
highly recommend that you run some
experiments to figure out whether you're
actually getting this kind of traffic
distribution because load balancers have
lots of intelligence built in that might
make us different I should say one quick
thing one thing that you need in order
to spin up the baseline here you need
access to the deployment configuration
of your current app and so that means
that you have to get that either from
the runtime or from a get ops repo or
whatever you have it's not just the new
deployment object that you need to spin
this up all right let me just bead up
here so we decide to go ahead great we
narrow down the label selector again we
update the new version it does its
rollout 1 2 3 wait done wonderful so now
we have our Canary deployment finished
so if we need more sophistication this
works and you can do vanilla Canary with
kubernetes as this pattern but if we
need some more sophistication we noticed
there were already some well a little
bit of sort of wouldn't say friction but
the the sizing was already a bit of a
challenge we can use this tio to do more
things series do as a service mesh heard
a lot about it has many more features
and many more use cases than just
traffic distribution in a canary rollout
but it's a very useful thing to use if
you're interested in doing a more
sophisticated canary - so there's two
main things that we're going to talk
about today
but a useful one is that it supports
fine-grain traffic splits and the other
that you can do content-based routing in
your canary as well I think that's a bit
of an advanced topic so everyone has to
go away and implement that but it's nice
to know that it's possible so there's
two sto resources that we need to know
about if we're going to use it like this
there's the destination rule and this
defines subset so that's resources to
which traffic should be sent and then
there's the virtual service which
defines the routing basically match
rules that say under these particular
conditions take the traffic and send it
over to these subsets and send this much
of a traffic so in practice a subset of
the llaman looks a bit like this over on
the destination rule you have a subset
called my app same label selector we
used and then over on the virtual
service side you have a route that says
take all the HTTP traffic and send it
over to subset my app and so the picture
looks quite similar to what we had just
now with kubernetes you've got your
destination rules up there you've got
your virtual service it has a subset
it's sending all the traffic over here
and now we know we add the two new
deployments that's outside of Sto that's
just regular kubernetes but now we add
this channel to our sto configuration we
define two new subsets oh it's it's much
more legible up there than it is here
which is nice we define the candidate in
the baseline and we use label selectors
to point specifically at those and then
we add a weight distribution over on the
virtual server side which says that
we're going to split the traffic 95/5 in
this case so we end up with a picture
that looks a little bit like this and
notice that we can have a traffic
distribution here that is different from
the sizing of the individual replicas
sets which is really nice so one of the
nice things we can do if you only have
5% of traffic on your canary in your
base line it might take a while to get
enough data to make a good canary
decision you might not want to wait that
long so as you've gained a little bit of
confidence that your Canaries doing well
you might want to ramp up the traffic
and you can do that really easily with
this kind of configuration change in sto
and then again without changing the
sizing you now have 80/10/10 which is
nice
one important point to bear in mind here
as you decide to ramp up more and more
traffic you pretty much want to make
sure that you have a horizontal port
autoscaler on those replicas sets
because you don't want them to fall over
as you send fifty percent of traffic or
forty percent or whatever to your canary
and your baseline or your candidate and
your baseline so now if we decide to go
ahead great we can get rid of the subset
definitions and we can change the weight
distribution back and we can update the
deployment object and then we make that
change and as before it goes through its
regular deployment pattern and we're
done we now have version two running
we've done a nice canary rollout with
kubernetes and sto so to add this little
kind of funky advanced topic into the
mix imagine we have some really critical
customers and we're really really
concerned that they should not have a
braking application on them so we really
want to make sure that they can you know
when we do a candidate evaluation they
don't get sent to the old version or the
new version rather so we can do content
the header based routing in this case to
do that I'll skip through this a little
bit you can define a match rule that
matches specifically on the header and
you can say under these circumstances
always send to my old subset Oh missing
a slide you know always sent am I always
sent to my old application and a one
thing that is obviously worth bearing in
mind that if you have these kind of
rules the traffic distribution that's
what that little star is changes a
little bit because of course the people
that match this specific condition are
going to the old version and so you end
up with ninety five five of the
remaining traffic alright quick overview
of the recommended pattern that we
talked about here in the steady state
you only need to keep the running
version of your application using a
deployment object when you start your
rollout and you want to do a canary you
create two new resources a candidate and
a baseline and you use the deployment
config of the of the existing version
for the baseline and you use the
deployment config of the new version for
the candidate you send you add subsets
to your destination rule and appropriate
weight distribution to your virtual
service it's useful if you're automating
the
if you think of the weights as
parameters to your automation scripting
or your automation tool because that
makes it easy to do a multi-step canary
now you can easily go from 80/10/10 to
or 90 or towards 60 20 20 something like
that and you should definitely use a
horizontal pod autoscaler for your
baseline and your candidate so that they
ramp up as the traffic comes up so then
you wait gather data and then you make a
decision if you're good to go after the
canary analysis you just update the
deployment that represents your running
app and get rid of the rest and you can
remove the subsets from the destination
rule and the weights from the virtual
service and of course you can get rid of
the candidate and the baseline workloads
there's lots of shortcuts possible here
you can for instance keep the candidate
in the baseline around and have them
spun down and that means that your llamó
changes might be a little simpler but
this is the sort of cleanest and nicest
approach because in your steady-state
you only have one running workload and
everything else is ephemeral during the
course of the rollout so speed up a bit
this could be an entire talk in its own
right one thing worth pointing out here
is that the rollout that we looked at
represents a sequence of six or seven
config changes and if you're thinking of
a get-ups style pattern where you want
to capture the intended state of your
runtime
in a repo the question becomes how do
you reflect these config changes in that
repo clearly you don't want to have your
users do cube CTL six or seven times as
you're doing this canary analysis so
automation tooling really should be
updating this repo another approach that
we see some of the community tooling
take is to basically hide this kind of
canary pattern inside the CRD so you
post something like a canary rollout and
it magically makes all the resources for
you and runs however long it runs and
that's possible but one of the things it
does is it means that your repository
doesn't really reflect the actual state
of your cluster very well because you
think you have one deployment but you
actually have three and so we think
having your automation tooling make
these updates back into your repository
is a good mix between making it simple
for the user they just need to say
deploy with canary and between having a
representation of your actual cluster
state so that you can see at any given
time what was really going on
more yes so a final summer here three
main takeaways from my side you can
implement canari rollouts and other
strategies that go beyond the vanilla
the deployment object in kubernetes you
can do that pretty easily using vanilla
kubernetes resources or if you want more
sophistication for canary you can use
sto add that and it gives you two nice
at least two nice powerful features
including traffic shaping and also
content based routing and then if you
want a recommended sequence of config
changes for your resources as you want
to do a canary rollout well we have one
in the slides over here you can easily
automate this set of config changes
using Spinnaker's you'll see right now
or indeed a bunch of other tools and now
to actually see what this looks like for
real let's hand it over to Norah awesome
a lot of great information thanks so
much so before we get into our demo here
I want to talk just really quickly about
who de Klerk Labs is what we're doing
why Canary robots are actually very
important to us so take heart we're
focusing on building models of the
physical world right things like
agriculture supply chains transportation
energy production four years ago the
founders spun out descartes labs from
the Los Alamos National Laboratory after
incubating their underlying machine
learning technology for many years so
then we took that and built a software
as a service platform on top of GCP that
our customers can leverage to build
their own machine learning models
utilizing petabytes of remote sensing
and geospatial data so to comprise this
platform we use about every GCP product
available I think except for maybe
exception of App Engine and spanner so
here's one quick example of how we we
build these models this is a natural
color imagery of farmland in greenfield
Iowa taken from cental to here's that
same imagery after going through our
pipelines so our platform has empowered
our applied scientists to segment up
that imagery into boundaries
of towns fields roads and then took a
machine learning classification model on
just the fields to show corn and soy
field boundaries and then we took that a
step further and we were able to use the
non-human visible spectrum of light and
seeing how it travels through the plant
does he how much fruit the plant is
growing and then we scaled that up using
kubernetes using hundreds of thousands
of cores tens of thousands of pods so we
can views this growth every single day
on every field everywhere in the United
States so why am i up here talking about
caring releases right obviously DevOps
is not our core business model but we
needed to always be improving feature
velocity right we need to move faster we
need to add new capabilities and
continue scaling up our platform but we
wanted to do this without introducing
issues that have cascading effects
across our complex interlocking services
detecting problems when new features are
released to production is actually
pretty hard but what if we could have a
way to detect them before they went
truly live and we wanted to do all of
this with minimal human intervention
right humans are good humans are great
engineers with lots of operational
experience are wonderful but they're not
infallible to be able to sustainably
meet our goals we needed a nuanced and
fully automated approach so these are
some of the circumstances that led us to
investigate tools to do things help us
do things like canary analysis and
canary deployments what we found when we
were trying to solve this problem can
kinda be split into three main
categories I'll briefly go over those we
looked at things like continuous
delivery we looked at a tool like tools
like git lab which is a very mature
delivery system required a lot of buying
into their ecosystem we also looked at a
lot of things like Jenkins scripts which
what seemed a bit heavyweight for our
use case kindly bring a chainsaw or we
need a scalpel and also the story to
implement Canaries was not as as clean
at the time we looked at it and then
finally we looked at spinnaker right
which is an open source projects but not
of Netflix for those not familiar it has
a feature-rich kubernetes v2 provider
that supports complex pipelines
consuming and producing kubernetes
native objects and hopefully it also
supports canary analysis through
something called canta and then next
we're talking we're looking to get those
metrics to be able to do our canary
analysis we need to be able to do those
fine-grained traffic splits so lucky for
us we're already using SD on production
so we didn't have to look very far there
and then finally when we looked how to
actually implement this in in practice
how to do these canary analyses we
actually at the time we looked last year
didn't find a very consistent pattern or
best practices guidelines as reported by
the community in fact what we did find
at that time was a lot of conflicting
approaches and so of course here today
I'm going to introduce one more approach
for for you all to consider so here's
what we use add a cart to power our
continuous deployment pipelines with
Canaries
my hope is you're going to take away
some ideas and concepts on how this can
work at your organization's so we have
spinnaker with cayenne 2 for canary
analysis we have kubernetes our
communities all run on gke and then
finally we have EST l so before I hop
into the demo I want to show you where
we're starting from like what is the
current state of affairs we have our our
service here tiles it's a real service
that we use to scale up analysis over
large geographic areas by splitting them
into a grid of smaller sized tiles we
have our deployment object or service
object and then we have our issue of
virtual service tiles release which
routes all of our production traffic to
our community service and then finally
we have our ingress gateway which is
receiving arriving all of our traffic
coming into our service mesh so what
we're going to try and do today
is update live to production version 2
of this app right here on stage so let's
go ahead and head to the demo alright
perfect
so here we have our spinnaker UI now
don't worry even haven't seen this
before it's a lot going on and come talk
to me after if you want to talk more
about the details of this and we're
gonna spend a lot of time talking about
the intricacies of configuring Canaries
for analysis so I'm not gonna spend a
lot of time on spinnaker concept as much
as how you fine-tune your canary
analysis because it's not just magic and
I'm gonna pull back the curtain it's
actually pretty nuanced so anyway let's
move on in our case we're using the
version 2 provider right which allows us
to manage many of our kubernetes kinds
deployments being one of those and also
sto kinds most relevantly to our
discussion here is going to be our
virtual service we have our application
canary which isn't actually a one-to-one
mapping with tiles but it does contain
our pipeline that we concerned we're
concerned about here which is our next
demo canary pipeline so if we click
through we can see that our pipeline
contains artifacts parameters and stages
stages consume those artifacts and
parameters some of them are canary
analysis stages in our case let's go
here the artifacts were concerned with
are for the tile service itself so we
have our deployment manifest capture
name github we have our virtual service
and then finally we have our tiles image
which is in GCR so let's finally just
jump into it let's kick off the pipeline
I'm gonna start a manual execution here
and I'm gonna supply an image tag which
of course is now not copied because my
computer turned off thank you
demo gods so
apply this isn't a parameter to bind to
our correct image and DC R&R deployment
manifest normally this pipeline would be
triggered by a pub/sub right so when a
new tag is made available the tag would
then be sent to spinnaker as part of the
payload so let's talk a little bit about
these stages as I start to run through
we have our get image from production
stage which produces an artifact namely
our tiles image that's currently running
in our tiles release deployment version
one right so this is what Andrew talked
about you need to get the image that's
running in production to be able to feed
that to your baseline so that's a pretty
critical moment this is going to be
consumed on the next stage so now we
have our Canaries and our baseline being
deployed canary is going to be deployed
with the candidate release image tag
baseline with the image tag that we
obtained from our previous stage
something to note here baselines and
Canaries are using identical horizontal
Padova scalers deployments and service
objects alright so this helps us
eliminate variations that can help that
could affect adversely analysis results
so once those finished deploying our
virtual service is going to be updated
for the first time to shift a production
percentage of production traffic away
from the production release and towards
the canary baseline pair so we're going
to start by shifting 10% of traffic to
each the canary and baseline services
and keep 80% running to our release we
have several stages in our pipeline that
manipulate the virtual service for tiles
release so we increase the weighting as
we go so more and more traffic heads to
canary and baseline something I think is
worth pointing out here is that instead
of maintaining versioning a virtual
service manifest for each and every of
these combination combinations
we're parameterizing this using
something called spinnaker expressions
and these are going to be evaluated
during each stage so let's go back here
and
all right so at this point our virtual
service is then templed it out and
deployed and we're going to move on to
our first canary analysis stage so this
stage is powered by Kayenta this is a
canary analysis service released jointly
by Google and Netflix that aggregates
and compares metrics for judgment
whether a canary is held healthy
relative to a baseline as I mentioned
this is now integrated into spinnaker
and can be enabled I'm not going to go
into that here but it's fully documented
and we're happy to talk about that later
so there's two main areas of
configuration when it comes to canary
analysis and the first is our canary
config so when our canary config we're
going to specify metrics that we want to
compare between a baseline and a canary
not shown here but actually very
relevant to this is our telemetry
provider right we can't compare anything
if we don't have metric information in
this case our Istria metrics are being
exported to stackdriver
right so we're gonna use Stafford for
our use case but you can also use things
like Prometheus data dog and others so
what can metric do we actually care
about for tiles what do we want to what
do we want to analyze are we trying to
add a new candidate release response
latency to client request is one metric
that's pretty important right we want
retrieval of tiles of rasterize David
data to be quick so it's not to impede
higher-level analysis so let's go ahead
and click into that metric we should
think of these metrics as a set of
templates right that are going to be xf4
queries they're going to execute against
your met your telemetry store for both
your baseline and your canary we're
going to define failure depending on
whether the canary metric is seen to
increase statistically relative to our
baseline in this case we want to fail if
the response latency is higher coming
from the canary we chose a resource
type that represents a set a set of time
series data that we want to measure in
this case kubernetes pot where they need
to choose a metric type that has data
specific to this resource so it's to
expose all sorts of great metrics right
out of the box that you can use in our
case we're measuring client round-trip
latency and this so this is a
distribution of latency values we then
want to use things like grouping and
filtering to further refine this date
these data points that you want to
compare right being able to get that
exactly the right data that you want to
compare is actually part of the the
biggest part of the nuance here so we're
gonna filter out unhealthy responses
anything not a 200 series response in
other metrics you may care very well
very much about whether or not itself
you're unhealthy but in this case we
want to consider healthy responses we
want to filter on the destination
workload name which is going to resolve
to either tiles based on their tiles
canary remember these are templates
where our namespace is tiles and a
request is a post because in this
particular execution path that we're
testing or sees post requests and then
we're going to take that and actually
clean that up and aggregate that a
little further we're gonna help smooth
out this distribution for better
comparison using aggregators aligners
and reducers so we want to choose the
50th percentile value of each latency
distribution as a single data point for
the whole period of one minute and why
do we do this right one of the reasons
we do this is we want a safeguard in our
analysis against things like a random
expensive request or a series of those
Network failures things like that they
don't creep in and actually only cause
false negatives and positives so by
aggregating this data you're gonna be
able to have a more apples to apples
comparison so let's go back here if you
do choose to analyze more than one
metric which is probably recommended
these can be grouped and those groups
can be weighted in importance one
example of why you might want to do
in our case we chose latency but if we
also had error rate as one of our
metrics in your this scenario latency
metric analysis shows that it's near
identical performance between canary and
baseline and so it will denounce as
successful but error rate is
significantly higher in the canary so
that should probably be weighted higher
as it has meant much more severe
implications for your service health and
for your customer experience and then
finally I'll briefly touch on scoring
thresholds so our marginal score is the
minimum value that a canary analysis can
have and still proceed on to further
analyses and our past score is the
minimum score value that the final
analysis should have in order to pass
for the entire stage in our case we're
only measuring one metric so it's kind
of a binary operation right either
you failed zero or you passed 100 so we
set our metric our scores to 99 and 100
respectively so the second piece of this
puzzle is the analysis stage itself in
the stage config we want to specify how
kayat is going to operate for this
particular analysis stage right we're
gonna set our analysis to real-time to
measure our deployments that are running
right now but you could also set this to
retrospective right so if you have a
Canarian baseline pair that have been
running in the past days the past weeks
the past months even you could have this
do the exact same analysis over that
that period of time but for this demo we
set real time we set our config name but
I think the most important value to set
here the most important thing to think
about is the lifetime value right
currently we have it set to 3 minutes
not a very long time that's for this
demo and I'll go into why this is so
important in order for your comparison
to be accurate and not reflect more
potential false negatives or positives
you want to set a long enough lifetime
to gather enough data points to ensure
that anomalies don't skew your analysis
right so you want to set a long time to
gather this data
we also set our baseline and canari
namespace and deployments here so after
analysis run is complete we can view our
analysis report once spinnaker loads so
in this amplitude versus time chart let
me zoom out a little bit so you can see
all of this at once
hopefully in step two diverses time
chart you can see that the comparison of
time series data we filtered out from
our sto client round trip latency metric
all right so it looks like our canary is
not introducing statistically
significant higher latency than the
baseline and so our analysis is
successful which is great you can also
view things like the maximum minimum and
average latency data points gleaned from
our 50th percentile time series and if
you actually click through here to your
metrics you can see all of your data
points that were gathered throughout the
lifetime but you're probably thinking
well nor that doesn't sound this doesn't
look very impressive right it's three
data points and this actually highlights
one of the issues with such a short
lifetime with a period of one minute an
analysis lifetime of three there's only
lost for three data points to be
aggregated with such a small sample size
analysis results may be less than
representative so it's very key that you
spend enough time gathering this data on
the order of hours and days not just
minutes so now that our analysis is
successful we're going to move on the
pipeline is going to move on and
increase the weights to our canary
baseline pair so we're gonna let's go
ahead and head back to the slides real
fast so at this point we're starting to
adjust our weights right we're read
updating that virtual service to set our
traffic to 20 20 and 60 and as this
occurs our traffic
and thus the CPU across each deployment
is going to increase and so our
horizontal pot autoscaler is going to be
able to begin to scale our tiles
baseline and tiles release as a function
of the load one of the ways to visualize
this is with stackdriver
here's a chart I created to view the
current numbers of tiles pods as
reflected by their CPU work at the
request counts you can see our release
deployment scaling up and down as a
function of traffic while our canary and
baseline are also scaling up to meet the
demand as virtual service weights are
increased so eventually our virtual
service will have waited the Canarian
baseline to receive 80% of traffic right
so we're very pretty confident at this
point we've got a healthy release and
then we're going to perform the final
analysis currently using our same config
and stage parameters as before the
reason you might do multiple analyses is
because behavior is going to change as
your candidate scales up right as you
scale it's going to introduce potential
issues things like memory leaks or a
slow-burning bug that sort of thing so
having multiple periods as you scale is
going to give you more confidence that
your candidate is actually healthy so if
that's successful our release deployment
is updated to use our new tiles image
tag version two and then we're going to
begin reversing this waiting process
letting our tiles released deployment
scale back up gradually as it receives
more and more the traffic again this is
so we don't shock the system so to speak
as our release has scaled down if we
reintroduced 100% of traffic that could
have a spite and Lane sees failures
unpredictable behavior so we want to
start scaling down our baseline first
because this is the oldest deployment at
this point and scaling up our production
release then we scale down the canary
until we have our successful release
it's important to note that regardless
of success or failure the canary and
baseline deployments are deleted and
tiles released is reset to receive 100
of traffic via virtual service this is
implemented by another pipeline that's
triggered after the previous is
completed or failed so wrap up here's
some pro tips I can give you guys when
you're looking to implement this
yourself alright choose metrics that
reflect key service health indicators
right so if your candidate release was
to go into production choose what you
would care to measure if you already
have things like service level
indicators have those established it's a
great starting place accruing a large
enough sample size and aligning the data
for apples to apples comparisons is
critical to avoid false negatives and
false positives having identical
baselines carries and releases except
for image tag helps ensure that you're
examining the right difference between
your service instances change one
variable for your analysis and I didn't
go it over it very much but every
deployment wars on a pot on a scaler
service and virtual service was fully
parameterised with spinnaker expressions
this meant I can avoid having to version
potentially hundreds or thousands of
manifests and dynamically populate them
at runtime with spinnaker parameters
this is a really powerful feature of
spinnaker and should absolutely be
taking advantage of and then finally the
way client interprets these metrics
labels from stack drivers a little bit
opaque so since we're using stack driver
I found personally found that using the
metrics Explorer very very helpful in
teasing out those mappings so take
advantage of the tools your metrics tor
provides to help you get this right so
canary analysis and CD for kubernetes is
a never moving target we want to work
with you guys the community to help
shape these patterns and tools I'd
recommend checking out the spinnaker
kubernetes special interest group and
the hash tag Cabernets channel on the
spinnaker slack to join in and then
finally a little plug come check us out
at Descartes labs comm if you're
interested in using our platform to
power your geospatial machine learning
models or just curious about what we
have to offer check out our API zat
docks that Descartes labs comm and if
you also
a love for geospatial data modeling the
earth want to solve tough engineering
challenges
check out address page or just shoot us
an email at hello at Descartes labs comm
all right Thank You Nora
[Applause]
[Music]